here's the reality of it with tate the
biggest challenge he's gonna have is
what
how much can the world consume that
content before they get over it is it a
one year thing is it a three year thing
is it a five or ten year
i think
he's not going away for a while i think
he is very attractive i think he's very
entertaining i think he's also a great
storyteller i think he makes very good
points i think he is multi-dimensional
he doesn't just talk about dating he
talks about politics he talks about
religion he talks about finance he'll
talk about sports he'll talk about
fighting
when you're that multi-dimensional you
can be in any room and you can be
interesting most people are not very
multi-dimensional if you were actually
to sit there
and take the top 20 content creators who
are out there going viral and you were
to say who are multi-dimensional kate's
on that list logan paul is
multi-dimensional you know you got you
don't have that many people that are
that multi-dimensional